yeah yeah hey TLS Oscar so Neujahr
Karaoke Franco Jahr nachdem ich Nibbana hatte
jetzt noch letzte Bananenpflanze ein groovy hey
me
das Dorf heißt queer academies of
spring besonders über diese Dörfer
die hier Gewächshäuser Gewächshäuser
weil hier viel
geothermische Energie
wächst  Manager des Gewächshaus-
Versuchsgewächshauses an der
Landwirtschaftsuniversität in Island, mein Großvater
hatte den Job, den ich jetzt habe. Er hatte
früher diesen Job, den er in Gesängen
des Bananenexperiments hatte, und er war
hier in den 60er Jahren auch Lehrer  Ich bin
sehr an diesen Ort gebunden. Wir haben
in den 1950er Jahren hier in Island angefangen, Bananen anzubauen,
weil es Probleme mit dem
Import von Bananen nach Island gab. Dann hatten wir
alles, um unsere eigenen Bananen anbauen zu können.
Alles lief gut, außer an
einem so dunklen Ort  Im Winter brauchten wir also
etwa 18 Monate, um eine Banane zu züchten,
und das war zu lange für uns,
um ohne Einkommen zu warten, man bekommt Tausende von
Gästen, die hierher kommen und davon kommen  zehn genug
sie fragen wo bekommt man solche
bananen wir sagen nur hier in diesem gewächshaus
wir wollten in diesem gewächshaus etwas mehr haben
als nur bananen wir haben
hier orangen und am ende haben
wir hier unseren kaffee wir verkaufen
nichts  die wir hier herstellen, aber wir verwenden
sie, da wir exotische Lebensmittel herstellen können. Meine Aufgabe
hier ist nicht nur, mich um
Bananen zu
kümmern und Bananen anzubauen  LED-Leuchten und
die HPS-Leuchten
Erdbeeren wie Süßigkeiten sind
etwas, das Sie kaufen, wenn Sie es sich leisten können,
aber wenn die Leute Probleme haben, kaufen sie keine
Erdbeeren, sondern
Tomaten.
Wir haben eine sogenannte Studentenkammer
, in der wir Paprikagurken
anbauen  Kirschtomaten normal große
Tomaten und die Schokoladenfleischtomaten
und wir haben auch schwarze Kirschtomaten
und orangefarbene Kirschtomaten. Oh nein, Sirene. Die
Menschen im Atlantik sind sehr konservativ, wir
di  Wir haben erst in den 1940er Jahren angefangen, Gemüse zu essen
, als wir vor zehn Jahren nicht wussten, was wir können, und wir haben davon gehört
, Arier, aber jetzt
lernen wir allmählich, dass
es mehr Dinge gibt, die man essen kann, als
nur Fisch und Fleisch  Die Erzeuger können
sogar jetzt alle ihre Produkte verkaufen, wenn es
ein bisschen mehr kostet, weil die
Menschen in Island ihrem
Essen vertrauen. Sie vertrauen darauf, dass die Erzeuger
genau das tun, was für sie richtig ist
gesünderes produkt als was wichtig ist
[musik]
hast du ein spezielles rezept mit dem
gemüse zum anbauen mag ich nicht mag
ich von einem künstler allein
ich hasse gekochtes gemüse ausser
tomaten etwas pfeffer und ich verwende sie einfach
im  Eintopf